is it true that it's your first talk
show yes it is my first time okay I
might have made something for you I mean
whatever Elsa made the really good one
but like which one would you like which
one would you like
Mike one I love pink
okay good color it's really messed up
it's a really messed up draft I just
started
don't judge me Ella I just started I
thought you were totally gonna pick
Alice's because it's legit so what was
your first talk show Allison I think it
was Craig Ferguson love Craig yeah it
was really fun he's funny he was so
funny yeah really great time but I do
remember getting I was very nervous yes
around you this is very chill but there
sometimes can be people that stress you
out
the / do you know like you know like
don't you get so stressed and people
stress just to be yourself cuz
everyone's trying to remind you what to
say and what to do and like just be
you're gonna just go with the flow yeah
and you're cool great acting about being
a part of this movie I think the coolest
thing about being part of this movie in
particular is that Harley Quinn doesn't
care about anything
she's just so crazy and it was so fun to
be with her and to just mess around and
be a kid yeah it's good when you you'll
learn that - just working on different
sets with different actors and different
people like especially if you start out
so nice with somebody that's really cool
and like lets you just be you and isn't
giving you no added pressure those are
the jobs you want so your character
birds-of-prey
is a pickpocket so did you study hard
for that one
can where's my wallet it's what I'm
saying I would be careful with a
magician from the Magic Castle he came
and taught me how to hit pocket and how
to work with a little bit of magic and
cards and I've always wanted to go to
the Magic Castle like what do they do
there I think it just seems like a
pocket that's maybe I don't want to go
there I like my money um so so what is
the key to stealing a wallet just for
asking for a friend
Wow well a magician never gives away
their co I like you I like you well
we've got a magician X if you both of
you I always love asking people this
usually it's after several drinks but
don't drink what superpower would you
want if you could pick any superpower I
think I'd want to be able to fly yeah
because I
I mean saving the world is great yeah
like just to be able to like look at
everything and just like transportation
yeah so I'll be there in a second yeah
yes yeah no traffic flex on all your
friends like I can fly I'm taller than
you away I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this